So let's dive in and talk about Parallel Optimization Patterns.
Now in the supplentary material, you'll find pointers to a fantastic couple of papers by
John Stratton and colleagues at the University of Illinois.
One is titled, "Optimization and Architecture Effects on GPU Computing and Workload Performance,"
and it was published in the Innovative Parallel Computing Conference in 2012.
A reworked version of that same basic paper was published later that year in IEEE Computer.
The Computer paper is a little shorter and more readable.
Now, what they did is survey a whole bunch of highly optimized
parallel codes, paid attention to the patterns that emerged, and extracted 7
fundamental techniques that come up over and over again.
And as you'll see, several of these techniques
encapsulate or formalize lessons that we've already learned.
So this will also be a good review of material that we've covered
in Unit 2 and Unit 5, and along the way in the homeworks.
Let's walk through the taxonomy of seven techniques that that they've come up with.